I know you're in there
[ __ ] doesn't have a dick he's got a
[ __ ] dick he just gotta talk to
identify yourselves [ __ ] I'm
Jay and this my head rule I've made
Silent Bob don't tell me you guys have
no idea there's a new comic book movie
being made of the old comic book movie
you two are the basis for that old a
star-studded piece of [ __ ] that movies
some balls
it's like [ __ ] - Your Honor I object
I'll allow it an [ __ ] we got three
days to get the Hollywood and stop this
review from every baby
Jay racers you're about to meet I think
I'm gonna need to see a blood test this
is my daughter can you take us to
Hollywood with you no man it's a tough
ass neighborhood either you take us to
Hollywood or stab you both to death on
my own [ __ ] lawn and on that note we
cue the music
glad you guys are smoking back there
that's driving someone about a week ago
you need to pay a big [ __ ] you have no
idea how hard it is to get the smell out
of pleather
[Music]
your methods what students
it's chained inside the table
I just found out I have a kid but I
don't know how to be a father
anybody would come he can be a fun but
only love can make you a dad
how you going to talk about love and you
flee and come all over the place
that's just see what do you guys think
about this reboot it sucks there I said
it
and who's directing this [ __ ] anyway
Kevin [ __ ] Smith smells like this
reboot and up and smoke
[Music]